from Taylor Swift and Brendon Urie to
the Jonas Brothers and BTS he's taking a
look at the most memorable moments of
the 2019 Billboard Music Awards Taylor
and Brendan opened up the awards show
with a Broadway worthy performance of
their new single meet earlier in the
night Taylor
lit up in lilac on the red carpet in a
race' and Vanessa mini-dress Taylor was
even spotted rocking out during Ciara
and Colleen's performances the 33 year
old singers hubby
Russell Wilson and son future were
adorably jammin out as well
incognito in the crowd Drake made a
surprise appearance looking dapper in a
maroon suit after winning the award for
top Billboard 200 album he gave this
hilarious shout-out to Game of Thrones
shout out to Arya Stark for putting in
that work last week
[Applause]
the Jonas Brothers took the stage for
their first award show performance back
together and the crowd went wild
including at the Jay sisters Danielle
Priyanka and Sophie more excitement from
the audience after BTS won the Billboard
award for best duo group sue can't
believe that we're here on this stage
which sucks so many great artists oh my
god party B showed off her rock solid
ABS both on the carpet and on stage
while accepting her award for top rap
song for her hit I like it like that
with bad bunny and J Balvin we talked
about your abs bro what are you doing
stop stop
you look amazing Mariah Carey was
honored with the Billboard icon award
icon I really don't think of myself in
that way and performed some of her
greatest hits from hero to emotion
and Taylor got emotional
[Applause]
and Mariah's kids adorably rocked out to
their mamas music in the crowd Paula
Abdul pulled out all the stops as she
closed out the show with an epic
performance in honor of her upcoming Las
Vegas residency
[Applause]
you